hello and welcome again to Android
design in action I'm your host Roman
Nurik hey guys my name is Adam Kush and
hi I'm Nick butcher and today we have a
special episode once again on home
screen widgets we're gonna take a look
at a couple of home screen widgets at
the very end a couple of home screen
widgets that we think you know do a good
job but first we're gonna talk about
designing home screen widgets how you
should approach them in general we're
going to talk about some design
guidelines for widgets and then talk
about some of the constraints since you
know as a designer you may not be fully
aware of you know the different types of
things you can and can't do with home
screen widgets so with that should we
just jump right in yeah let's do it all
right okay so what is a home screen
widget well you know according to the
design guidelines the link down there is
at the bottom so widgets are an
essential aspect of the home screen
customization you can imagine them as at
a glance views of the naps most
important data and functionality I'd
actually add latest data as well here
since widget is very important the
widgets are up-to-date
and it's accessible right from the
user's home screen users can move
widgets across from their home screen
panels and it supported resize them so
that's another kind of important aspect
is the customizability the fact that you
can basically take a widget move it
wherever you want it to whichever home
screen you want resize it to fit
whatever you know icons are around it
it's really kind of there to make it
your own so that's a home screen widget
at a very high level kind of overview
the idea is that you know you basically
take a part of your app and and throw it
onto the home screen and interject it's
one of the you know uniquely Android
features that I love to see in an
application and you can't get much more
prime real estate than owning a small
piece of the user's home screen and this
is where most of their user journeys
that are going to start from I know
personally you know you kind of on the
bus you're bored you're just flicking
around your phone seeing what's going on
I'd love to be able to see the latest
information it's similar to the rules
which
Alex went through last week about
notifications without that kind of
pressing time sensitivity or a person
waiting for it it's kind of like the
latest information that the user has
opted in and requests it to be notified
about is kind of like brought and like
you know surface to the user and it's
such a great opportunity it's such a
shame when an application with this kind
of information doesn't take advantage I
think of a home screen widget yeah
almost like you know I'd say that you
know there are certain users that if
they are a guess if you add a home
screen widget it's probably a pretty
strong signal that you're pretty
passionate about the app so some of your
you know biggest power users will be the
ones that use the home screen widget you
know not everybody will use it you know
not everybody decides to add it to their
home screen but the folks that do really
probably love your content so let's move
on so there are a few types of home
screen widgets so if you look at the
design guidelines they'll talk about
these but they're roughly broken up into
into three main categories information
type widget like whether that shows you
information at a glance control widgets
that let you kind of you know make
changes to a certain app or even the
system in this case and collection
widgets which basically let you see
collections of data scrolling vertically
to see kind of past items or other items
in the list and then of course there's
the the hybrid type of widget that
includes multiple items and most widgets
are probably going to be kind of hybrid
widgets they'll include aspects of you
know showing information also allowing
you access to you know control of the
app or potentially you know linking you
into different parts of the app which
we'll talk about in a bit and so you
know there are a couple things that I
think make a home screen widget really
good a couple of key important items so
the first is up-to-date you know home
screen widget should be dynamic it
should never really be you know just
showing one piece of information from
you know a week ago or two weeks ago it
should really be something that the user
you know would open up their home screen
and expect to you know see the latest
and greatest information so for example
if it's you know if you have a for some
reason a widget that does traffic then
you should probably show something
that's very immediate
something that's that's relevant to the
next you know a few hours if you have
something if you have a widget that's
showing weather also you want to show
something that's kind of around now you
don't want to show weather from
yesterday or something like that as well
as you know news articles or Gmail or or
or any sort of sort of you know list or
feed type widget you want to make sure
to to basically update the widget as
soon as there's new data so for example
in the case of Gmail you know when you
get a new email there's a push message
that's sent to the device that basically
tells Gmail the Gmail application that
hey there's a new email so along with
you know updating the you know the
cached content for Gmail you should also
make sure to trigger an update to the
widget so the widget can can show that
new information and this is all possible
as a developer you can all you could do
this of course but as a designer you
should you should plan for for push
updates to your widget as the
information comes in you can also
specify a parry a periodic refresh and
absolutely you know most widgets should
probably refresh automatically unless
there's you know some great reason not
to and generally you don't want to
refresh too often like for example
refreshing once a minute or you know
once every few minutes even that's
pretty pretty dangerous because you may
kind of you know suck up battery life
and basically you should you should
probably optimize around refreshes of no
more frequent than say you know once
every half hour to an hour that's
probably the the peak or the the minimum
bar for the minimum refresh time for a
widget without you know using too much
battery life the other thing to note is
that if you there's a lot of ways to
tweak this but should also be conscious
of when you update so do you want to
sure you want to update when the screen
or when the phone is sleeping or do you
want to update only when the phone is
awake and those are things that as a
developer you can control but as a
designer you should also be aware of the
different types of updates you can do
for religions the other most of the
other very important thing about a
widget is that it should be actionable
so you know it's one thing to just show
information but generally the
information you show is a snippet right
so you don't actually just want to end
the experience there you want to somehow
let the user you know dive deeper if
they actually care about the the news
story that you're showing for example in
your widget let them touch on that story
and jump into you know the details for
that so that they can read it like a
teaser when I think of like a newspaper
headline right so you want to be able to
tease these and entice them to click
through to more details right absolutely
and another thing to point out and Nick
will talk about this later but it's
important to note that widgets can have
different linkable regions so you know
make sure to be aware of you know what
are the different types of things user
would want to do from this widget and
tailor to those different behaviors the
other thing is that a widget should be
very very customizable so you know again
the the idea is that a user is granting
their precious real estate to you right
there they're giving away part of their
home screen to you so you should make
sure to make your widget as customizable
as you feel is fit in the sense that you
know make sure that it is resizable you
know one of the worst things is when a
user finds a widget that that can't be
reset is there can't be that or it's too
large and then it's kind of it's
requesting too much of that precious
real estate so make sure that you design
your widgets to scout the different
sizes the other thing is that you know
you should really want to show
information that's custom tailored to
the user so for example if it's if it's
like a reader type thing or a feed
consumption app and the user has a list
of favorite favorite feeds that you want
to see make sure to make that the
default option but let them obviously
customize if they want to change things
around and then also note that there is
a the option of a configuration step so
before the user or after the user
selects which you which widget to add
you have the option of providing an
inter kind of an interstitial page where
they can customize what should be shown
in the widget so make sure to make use
of that as well so again in the case of
the feed reader example you want to give
them the option to to specify which
feeds they'd like to see in that would
and that's probably preferable to having
multiple widgets maybe even though the
application can rather than having you
know 10 15 different widgets for all you
know different fear to application might
be able to produce it's preferable to
probably have just the one and then
configurations them right in so in past
versions of Android you weren't able to
create resizable widgets so a lot of one
of the biggest workarounds was let's
just create you know four different
widgets at four different sizes on newer
versions of the platform you should hide
away all those widgets you should only
really show the single widget that is
resizable that's the best approach so
let's move on and talk about the
guidelines Nick do you want to kick us
off here yeah so speaking of sizing and
the way that the widget kind of system
works is you have a number of cells on
your home screen so one cell is
typically the size of a an application
shortcut and so when you're designing
your widget you want to be cognizant of
when you use this place the widget on
the home team they're going to allocate
it and number of cells so hopefully
you're using a resizable we did say you
want to and what you would do is you'd
set the minimum number of cells which it
makes sense of the information you're
going to present and then let the user
kind of resize it by the number of cells
so when you come to actually designing
that you need to think about a few
things the first thing is that this
cells aren't really that deterministic
right they can be there's a slight
amount of flexibility in the actual size
depending on the device implementation
so you know if the home screen is in
landscape or portrait you know the
actual number of pixels may vary
slightly so you need to be and to build
a lot of flexibility into your widget
really so it can cope with a little bit
of change either way of the ideal
boundary sizes
and also they're saying worth bearing in
mind that the actual pixel size and the
way that we handled margins has changed
slightly in newer versions of Android so
previously we used to leave it up to up
to the developer to include any padding
inside with the bounce so we're just
given the cell and let them draw
anywhere that like within it and would
hope that they would include as central
massive padding's and we decided to
change that number at 4.0 and primarily
to to help keep the home to be slightly
more aligned so that everyone was using
similar and got the same padding so that
everything kind of was a nice tight grid
so you need to be aware of that so we've
included here the formula which we use
to calculate the size of the cells in in
in DP units so bear these in mind when
you're creating widgets if you're
talking just for point number above you
might want to use one formula if you
were target older devices and you need
to bear in mind how much padding to
allow for and one other thing I wanted
to add is that this is kind of a good
guideline to follow for minimum sizes
but note that you know the widget may
actually grow so for example on a tablet
let's say write the the home screen if
you if you rotate the the device from
landscape to portrait the cells aren't
actually still perfectly square they're
they're actually never perfectly square
as far as I know the idea is that in
landscape this the cells are slightly
wider and in portrait the cells are
slightly taller so designing with this
formula in mind will give you a good
minimum size but note that it can kind
of grow and shrink based on different
different orientations as well as
different devices different devices have
slightly different cell sizes but this
is a very good day we'll get more into
the layout and controls that you can
actually use in your app but basically
yet better in mind and thinking in terms
of scaling layouts and how they're going
to stretch and fill these differently
sized cells all right for the next slide
aren't falling yeah so styling is very
important I think we were talking
earlier we were talking about you are
occupying you know the users of giving
you a small amount of space on their
home screen so you really need to kind
of
you know fit in with the rest of the
homescreen and the other apps on there
so for that reason you really want to be
following fit even for rest of the
platforms are following the holo styling
guidelines it's a great start and to fit
in with what other widgets are going to
look like on the home screen as well as
the standard visual style of you know
the app shortcuts and so on
we found that subtle transparency works
really well here because the user has
chosen their their you know their
personal wallpaper and you know so to
work nicely at that and to go with their
color scheme to find a transparency can
work quite well their lines also to the
system which is how we do that as well
you know just one point I wanted to
point out so a lot of the system will
just actually have subtle transparency
it's not showing up well here in the
slides but the idea is that you know in
very very small parts of the widget
you'll see a little bit of the
background peek through and it kind of
gives that extra feeling of you know
digital right that this is actually you
know it's a real object but it's
actually something that's living in my
digital world yeah exactly and I think
the users chose the background and
purpose you know so you know you feel
like you know sense of ownership with
that connection with that and I think it
reinforces the fact that you're on the
user's home screen right they've chosen
to give you this piece of space as well
that you blend in well with it like
literally by using this kind of a design
principles and the last thing I'm going
to pull out here is yeah it's even
though you are you know not in the full
app mode you want to be doing all the
good practices like including press stay
or inactive estate of all your elements
because they are still interactive
elements they still need to respond to
touch and the other thing about press
States is that you know since again your
your on the user's home screen where you
know generally the the press states are
kind of you know using a blue glow for
example for icons or for different
widgets they're probably using that kind
of semi-transparent blue overlay you
want to use a similar press state if
possible if it fits in with your theme
because again you want the we we
generally want the homescreen to feel
like a single unified experience and as
much as widgets can do to to fall into
you know it fall in place and just kind
of be cohesive with the rest of the
launcher that's very important yeah I
mean you know just as your job when
you're building an app is to
your brand's visual style with the
Android visual style you mean this is
all the more likely leaning towards the
default and proficient start on the home
screen because you're going to be
shoulder to show that with all these
other players as well right yeah
personally if the styling and the
padding are off for a particular widget
I'm probably gonna remove it from my
home screen like it just doesn't fit
doesn't feel it fit in with the flow of
the home screen so I think this slide in
the previous slide are very important -
can you squeeze it precious things
there's our musings of people who are
just around sharing images of how they
can figure that Hosemann right people
get very passionate about this stuff so
yeah I mean it's something you see you
know I don't know about a few hundred
times a day when you see possibly see it
possibly a hundred times a day so you
want to make it as beautiful as possible
okay and then next up is a personal
bugbear of mine which is applications we
don't provide them a preview image so
you can provide one preview image per
widget and this is used not only in the
tray here so when I'm going through
selecting a widget I go into the widget
tray and then long press one let's pick
it up and then place up my home screen
but also when I'm placing it a slightly
semi-transparent version will be a hold
onto an hover to place it where I want
on the home screen so it's really
important to include this visual image
of what the witch is going to look like
and you need to when you're creating
these when they're placed into the tray
you'd be aware that you have this kind
of landscape crops representation so if
you provide a very tall widget it's
going to do like a center top crop so if
you look in this example we're showing
here the photo gallery widget it's
showing kind of like the top half almost
of the preview image which is fine but
just bear that in mind when you're
designing the asset that it may be
displayed as such and then when I pick
it up to place it on the home screen it
will display the whole image
semi-transparent white and also when
you're creating this you want to be
covers and not to be leaking any
personal data or anything like that you
want to create these with test data just
when you when you're designing them I
wanna one general technique that I've
used when creating widgets is basically
you know take a screenshot of the widget
open it up in Photoshop and you know I'm
guessing that as a designer you probably
have some of the source assets anyway
but drop in the source assets on top of
your your screenshot kind of you know
line things up appropriately and then
just replace all the the real data with
dummy data and then take you know export
that as a PNG file and drop it in as a
preview image the other thing to note
about preview images is that you try to
avoid showing any extra transparent
pixels around the sides of the preview
image since the launcher will
automatically apply padding and margins
so that your preview image isn't kind of
flush with the bounds of its cell should
we move on yeah absolutely all right and
this is a few more guidelines we talked
we touched briefly on the configuration
but this is kind of an example what it
might look like so if you if you drop
the Google Play and the library video it
shows you all your books and movies
you've been watching lately you'll get
this dialogue which will pop up offering
you if you want to personalize it's just
one of the media sources and so some
general guidelines about creating these
configuration steps is you want to keep
it very light I mean if you want to make
it personalizable but you don't want to
be leading the user for you know five
six seven deep and series of steps this
is suppose to be quite light process to
grab something and place it onto the
home screen so do keep that in mind and
the other things we do recommend is to
use a dialogue style here this is one of
the very few cases against where we
recommend a dialogue and just to give
the user in the context that they're you
know you are actually working on
something on the home screen and you're
not like deep in the app to getting one
there where they were coming from
hopefully
so now I'm through linking a little bit
deeper about linking through to content
so as we talked about earlier it's all
about you know and never having you to
expose your content so you want to be
having items of content so here this
email widget individual email - might be
individual news stories and they want to
be deep links straight through to that
to that content this isn't just the
launch of widget they want to be able to
go straight have these other avenues go
straight to to read more about it but
you also want to include access point
since you have other common points in
your application the user might want to
get - so typically we see that as being
the top level of the application and
quite quite often you'll use the your
app icon in the top left like similar to
the action bar pattern as to quick
access to the the root of the
application so that means the user
doesn't have to have you know if you
didn't have this you might have this
deep links groups the emails but then
you might also have to have an email
topic you know you want to remove that
the users going all out and putting a
widget on the home screen they don't
want to have a shortcut to the
application as well as kind of one or
the other
so give them a way to get to the top of
the app as well as the comment our state
in the email example again creating
creating a new email is an example here
it might be you know taking in photo
whatever it might be
and just a little note there mostly for
those developers out there really is
there are recommendations on navigation
is that if you do deep link into the
application you should be synthesizing
the tasks that all right let's move on
to the lockscreen one of my favorite
parts of that would you bring your hat
yes what are the the new shiny teachers
in Android 4.2 is the ability to play
switch it's not only on the home screen
but on the lockscreen and talk about
immediate info and control you don't get
much more immediate than that you know
this is like zero interaction
information you just have to turn the
telephone on and that's it right you
don't even have someone lock it and so
some things to be aware of is that the
we allow slightly less personalization
options on the lock screen widgets
essentially running two sizes so you can
see on the slide here there's an example
of the conduit chip and so either you
have the the ability to unlock so that
could be this slide I'm not lost and
I've like secured in my and which case
the widget is in like a collapsed state
or it takes it the whole screen there's
no kind of in-between state there's a
another thing to note on that is that
you actually can have multiple widgets
on the lock screen this is just an
example of one but you know as of
Android 4.2 you can actually add more
items to the left or I believe they're
actually all to the left to the right
there's the camera but so the left you
can add other items so we're the center
widget were the first thing you see when
you you know unlock your when you when
you press the power button the first
thing you see may be the clock if you
swipe to the left you can actually add
widgets there and those will always be
expanded you think I wonder if you look
at the end the back speech are they
expanded and kind of you can see there's
an extra panel peeking in to the side
yeah I make that appearance of each
other yeah you can swipe across other
ones the other thing to notice that on
tablets
there is no collapsed view there's just
expanded view this is kind of the
current presentation of things I mean
these things may change in the future
and certainly I don't think we have
guidance on you know third-party devices
or
you know other OEMs how they would you
know present lock screen widgets there
are certainly lots of different options
but the core API you should assume that
there will be a collapsed and expanded
state in some cases no no collapse team
and speaking of the current presentation
right now we we darken the wallpaper
slightly I think it's about 40% that's
something like something like that I
forget exactly so all of our you know
the the stock controls like to actually
go ahead and unlock the device and so on
or monochrome white on top of that and
that contrasts well with you know
because obviously the user control of
the wallpaper is behind so yeah using
white as there is the kind of the main
color in your design will work well here
it's at the moment guaranteed to kind of
like contrast okay one quick note on the
development side is it's just really one
extra XML attribute that you need to add
to make your widget compatible with both
the home screen and the lock screen but
obviously not all home screen widgets
you know should be placed or should be
allowed to be placed on the on the lock
screen it really comes down to the
application and the information you try
to display yeah you may even want and by
the way when you add a lock screen
widget you do again have the option of
providing a configuration step you may
want to ask the user you know what are
you comfortable showing on the lock
screen do you want to show all the
information or maybe you know just just
a snippet of information that doesn't
include personal information or you know
contact information from other people
but but definitely keep in mind that
there's this extra place here where you
potentially have you know insecure
access to the device can somebody can
just you know walk by the the users you
know cubicle see their phone and you
know if this is a bad person they can
you know you know take a look at the
phone if they don't know the pattern
they'll still be able to access the lock
screen widgets so if those have to you
know insecure information that's a
problem so I'm probably not going to put
my my bank account balance right but
something like it's do list like one of
my favorite to-do list I use it lets me
do they look to be widget so I'm
shopping I'm walking around the shops I
don't even have to unlock my device to
take things off as I walk around the
Isles place them in like
I can just literally turn the screen on
tick-tick-tick
done yeah that's great awesome okay
oh actually there's one more thing I
want to mention when you actually touch
an item on a lockscreen widget like
let's say you were to touch this this I
guess this calendar item you'd actually
be given the option first to to unlock
if you don't unlock the device it'll
actually just cancel that that click so
keep in mind that what's on the widget
is insecure but once you touch on
something it will be secure so
constraints is our constraints so there
are a couple of constraints that that
you should keep in mind when you're
designing home screen widgets the first
is there isn't really support for custom
fonts so from a developer standpoint I
mean in your app you can actually just
specify a font file a true type font
file to use for a given view or there's
a label or a piece of edit text or
something like that but on widgets
there's no real way to do that there is
a hack you know you can obviously you
know render the text into a bitmap into
an image and throw that into the widget
but that's just a really really bad hack
it's it's very bad for performance
things like that so just avoid custom
fonts if possible there's also no
opportunity for custom animations this
is something that a few designers have
asked me like what can I really do can I
make cool transitions when I press one
thing the widget rotates unfortunately
the widget framework right now is a
little static so you know if you touch
on something in the widget you can
update the widget you can change the
contents you know show something expand
or whatnot but you won't be able to
animate it really well so you're just
kind of assume that there won't be
animations one thing to note is that if
you're touching an item and jumping into
the full-screen view like linking deep
linking into content as of Android 4.1
there is something called activity
options where you can basically create
kind of a zoom up animation from the
content but that's basically the limit
of the
abilities you can do with widgets
actually there's also the option of a
cross fading between views we'll talk
about that in a second also there's no
horizontal gesture support so you know
the homescreen the the main way you
navigate the home screen and a lock
screen is you swipe left and right to
change between your different screens
that's since that's a very kind of
important gesture
we don't allow widgets to contain views
that can horizontally scroll as well so
the only type of scrolling or we're kind
of flinging or anything like that you
can do is vertical and and to do that
you need to use one of the specific
views which we'll talk about also
vertical scrolling is only available as
of Android 3.0 resize ability basically
the ability to you know long press on
the widget and then get those nice
little resize handles is only an Android
3.1 and then there's also we added this
option to change the layout of your
widget based on its size dynamically and
so basically after you resize you can
update the the layout of the widget and
that was added in jellybean Android 4.1
so in earlier versions you basically
kind of stuck with your layout once you
placed it and even after you resized it
until the next time you updated it I
think we mentioned this lock screen
widgets at full point to plus as well
right so there's some of the constraints
the other things too the other thing to
keep in mind is that there are certain
things you just can't do in widgets for
example you can't play video in widgets
you can't do create you can't play a
game in a widget you can't like draw
arbitrary stuff into the widget there
are a few kind of standard things that
you can do though the common things like
text labels and images and buttons those
work their support for loading spinners
as well progress bars as well although
like we mentioned before you don't want
to update the widget very very
frequently so it's not really feasible
to have a progress bar that updates you
know as you're downloading something for
example so progress bars you should
probably only use for like you know
percent watched for example you know if
if the widget is showing the latest TV
show episode that I've seen and I've
seen fifty percent of it maybe you can
use a progress bar to show that I've
seen 50 percent of
but don't show something that is
supposed to update very very frequently
you can also show an in-place carousel
basically you have like an image in
place in the widget and then you know
after a few seconds it kind of fades out
into another image you can do something
like that a good example of that is the
the news and weather widget that comes
by default with with like you know Nexus
4 things like that
and that's kind of an alternative to a
collection widget that basically lets
you you know scroll up and down and then
you can you can add some clocks in there
if you really want also for scrollable
elements you can have list views and
bita list view I don't mean specifically
a basically a view containing a you know
a list item or like a piece of text
followed by another piece of text your
list items themselves the items you show
in this list view can be fairly complex
you know you can do lots of different
things in them so don't treat this as a
list view think of it more as like a
basic kind of like collection view that
can show you know list items or
different presentations the email and
counter examples I guess we and we show
you briefly earlier and good examples of
that we have a you know quite a lot of
different spec content in that list view
user thing for it and also you can have
grid views so for example the bookmarks
widget lets you lets you see kind of a
two column a view of bookmarks so that's
another example and you can actually
replicate that using a list view as well
and then finally stack view which will
show an example of in a bit and then
most of the layout types you know as a
designer you may not be aware of the
different layout types but you know
there are things like relative layout
where things are arranged relative to
one another linear layout where things
are arranged linearly and frame layout
and things like that all those main ones
are supported so if it's you know you
you have a lot of options in terms of
where things are placed within the
widget so that's kind of one of the the
more open parts of the widget system
so those are the support UI elements
let's let's actually then just jump into
example since I think we're probably
running a little low on time yeah all
right let's so we had some screenshots
but we thought hey we've actually got a
device connected why don't we actually
demo these widgets like so he added just
a few widgets that we like to to the
home screen of this device first of all
we've got some news widgets there's the
New York Times and the BBC News widgets
they're both three sizable widgets both
vertically scrolling so here you can see
the New York Times we've got a list of
different news articles some headline
text some summary text and sort of an
image in most cases here on the right
all right
sorry you show you how the resizing
works yeah you just pick up the widget
and drop it and then you can very easily
resize it right there and then the BBC
news widget actually what I might do is
put this guy over here so you can see
bit better this is quite a nice widget
as well and when you expand it out there
it actually grows the columns quite
nicely here's probably a grid view right
I'm guessing I think of you so that's a
great example I mean this is coming for
free it's a great view but you want your
widget to dynamically resize like to
base long you know if I give it more
horizontal real estate that you might
change a representation of the story
like going into multiple rows of a grid
or you might show a more detailed
headline or something along those lines
you want your widget to react and make
the most of those of that space yeah I
really like these were just quite nice
for news news widgets and I think both
of them when you add them you get to
configure which category of news that
you want to actually show here so you
know you can show technology news on
your home screen if that's what's
interesting to you or you can show top
news in these cases so that some news
widgets this is the Google Play in my
library widget which is quite nice
because actually how much room do we
have here yeah that's fine if you if you
see that as you resize it and let go of
the resizing handles it relay up we re
lays itself out I guess you think and
it's quite nice because it fits
dynamically into sort of all sorts of
different sizes here so you can have a
small one if that's what you want to use
on your home screen can
would be wider widget here and it shows
the sort of various items for your play
library it's one of my favorite widgets
actually I think it's a great example of
what Roma's talking about earlier about
having really current really up state
information so if you have a lot of
information in place if you use play
music and books and everything and
movies then it all updates it's very
easy to get back to what you were last
last doing so if I'm reading a book on
my phone on my commute home and I get
home I can just pick up my tablet and
the FM the widget is updated to show
that you know that book is the most
prominent thing in the widget and I can
just click it to get it straight back to
where I was which is pretty abusive I
think yeah it's pretty nice over here
we've got some sort of miscellaneous
widgets I've got the Songkick widget
here which shows sort of your plans
upcoming constants that you have planned
got the Google+ widget and the Google+
widget actually it lets you it's not a
collection widget but it lets you flip
between different items using a button
on screen so you just press this button
and flip through the different items and
you know I I generally prefer the
collection type widget but this is
definitely another way to kind of focus
on a single item and actively have the
user switch between them and down the
bottom it's the the play music widget
yeah what's going on here which one is
that
that's the cards widget app so
currencies are uploading some stuck
waiting so long it's it's a collections
widget again it's actually similar to
this YouTube widget here we can flip
between the different cards and that's
an example of a stack view widget so
it's it's another type of collection but
it's just presented in a different way
autumn advanced which is kind of fun so
if you have something like a YouTube
where there's you know you probably tell
you about the latest videos edits to a
playlist you can they leave it there on
the home screen and it'll actually
rotate through and highlight that
content which is kind of cool yeah it's
a good way to present passive content
right so not like emails for example
that are obviously very important to
these are but you know featured items or
recommended items that the user may find
enjoyable and then finally we've got
sort of a collection of clock clock
widgets and actually the the one in the
center there is a dash
widget built by Roman Nurik himself and
it's also open source as well so it's
actually a good one for you know
developers and designers to go look at
how it was built and the way the way
these work actually just want to point
out is that this is an analog clock an
analog clock actually you can customize
as a designer you can tweak the the hour
hand the minute hand and basically the
system just rotates those those PNG
files to make it right and then here
there's a something called a text clock
that basically you just give it what
part of the time you want to show and it
shows that and you can customize the
different like typography aspects like
font weight and things like that as well
as colors and so on and you can see here
as you resize the the - clock widget it
shows it goes into a sort of summary
view and as you expand it it jumps back
out again so that's that's that's it
some of the demos right yeah
jump back to evany I think that was it
so um alright that was a there's one
more thing which i've seen a couple of
application series and like we're saying
they're their home screen widget is
prime prime real estate on the user's
home screen and the fact that they've
put you on the home screen means they're
probably quite engaging your project
products so I think it's touching
opportunity to use them quite
intelligently so yes you can highlight
the newest latest information but one
interesting example us in is a shopping
app where if you've abandoned a shopping
cart you know it will it has a widget
showing you the latest you know offers
or whatever it is targeted to the user
but it will actually insert the like a
top saying you know white you finished
your journey and so on so forth so I
think think of them you know remember
that they're real the small versions of
your app almost and not just a way to
highlight your interesting content so
think about interesting ways that you
can use your hosting widgets
absolutely and also we should probably
mention there's there are some
categories if you're building an app in
a certain category you pretty much have
to build a widget or else you your users
will comment like where is your widget a
couple examples you know if you're
building a sports app you should
probably have you know scores a scores
widget for your league or or for
whatever you know information you have
for building a music a band music
absolutely I'd have more advanced
support controls so yeah definitely
we build a widget all right well with
that thanks for joining a couple of
announcements before we sign off so as
we mentioned a few weeks ago on the show
the the engine is on an action show in
the app clinic show we're actually
starting to kind of integrate a little
better so when we do a topic on Tuesday
the folks over in Mountain View
California will be doing the same topic
the same general category on Friday so
tune in this Friday to the app clinic to
check out their thoughts on home screen
widgets all right with that I'm your
host Roman Nurik
see you guys Adam gosh bye I'm Nick
butcher
alright see you guys next week